I guess well thank you  [Music]  [Music]  the world is at your feet go to a spa  you're going to become a doctor  here's the passion  [Music]  Christopher Myers curtains with flower  reporter for The Associated Press  a toast to old friends and you  I'm a is a fine woman because you make  me feel I've come home she's very fond  of you it's obvious it's very dangerous  Armenians right now I will get you out  of here it's not safe for me then it's  not safe bringing my people  it is located pressing in reporting on  the war in the warrior  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  I have to get a car for this no time  left I was told that your guys missed  game right how can I help  do you love  the glass rod  Oh No  great  we will going to future together  [Music]  you